[Musique]
il y à 50 à nous ça fait disparaître la
moitié de la population de l'univers
mais les habitants de cette planète sont
parvenus à ramener tout le monde d'un
simple claquement de doigts
ce brusque retour de la population
à générer l'énergie nécessaire pour
déclencher l'émergence
il nous reste combien de temps nous
avons sept jours
[Musique]
nous sommes les éternels
nous sommes arrivés il ya 7000 ans
[Musique]
pour protéger les humains des déviants
pourquoi vous n'avez pas lutter contre
thanos ni empêcher toutes les horreurs
qui sont produites au cours de
l'histoire
nous avions ordre de rester en dehors
des conflits qui n'appliquaient pas les
déviants qui l'a ordonnée
[Musique]
il faut retrouver les autres
il y en a que je n'ai pas revu depuis
des siècles
salut salut
si la fin du monde ressemble à ça
on est aux premières loges tu sais ce
qui n'a jamais sauvé cette planète tu es
sarcasmes
nous avons aimé ce peuple dès le jour de
notre arrivée
quand on tient une chose
on la protège
[Applaudissements]
tu ne les protégera pas
[Musique]
aucun d'entre eux
j'suis paraît que cette planque est
indestructible c'est quoi cette table
dit vibranium non
collection d'automne iker
[Musique]